I have to hand it to him he does it all
she did what it takes to make this what
it is Lady Gaga and Bradley Cooper can't
stop praising each other as they gear up
to release their new musical drama a
star is born almost every single person
has told me they liked the way I sounded
but that they didn't like the way I look
I think you're beautiful tell me about
the first moment Bradley contacted you
about playing this role and what it
meant to you and what you talked about
well I actually was performing at a
cancer fundraiser for Sean Parker and I
was sang the song levy on Rose which not
to give it away but it is in the film
and I sang that song and the very next
day he wanted to meet me and he came
over to my home and I opened the door
and the second I looked into his eyes I
felt an instant connection to him I
think you know some of it is that we're
both from the East Coast you know we're
both coming from Italian families I was
like are you hungry I I cooked him up
some leftover pasta and we were eating
and then before I knew it he said I
would like to sing with you if that's
okay and we went to the piano and I
printed out the sheet music for a song
that he wanted to sing called midnight
special and I sat down and started to
play and he began to sing and I just
stopped instantly in my tracks and I
looked at him and I said Bradley you
have an incredible voice you sing from
your gut you sing from your soul you
sing from the nectar of your being
that's all you can ask for for a singer
as someone that can tell a story and
then he said should we film it so he
filmed it on his iPhone and we all of a
sudden started to sing together and
harmonizing and laughing and looking at
each other it was instantaneous and I
knew in this moment that I could make
this film with him and I truly believe
there's no actor or director in the
world that could have played this role
or who could have made this film can you
tell me what you remember from that
night I remember it was daytime but I
remember every single moment of it from
the minute you walked down the stairs it
was one of those magical things and for
it to be Lady Gaga and have that
connection and then have that commitment
from her it really is commitment she you
know she's very busy has a whole life a
whole profession and she she did what it
takes to make this
what it is and that that that I over
forever maybe it's down
[Applause]
Radley and you you've done so many do at
some this record and the soundtrack do
you think he should put out a solo
record you said he can sing should there
be a stew he can do anything when what
yes of course he'll ride on it is there
a Bradley Cooper album at all in the
future so no I mean that wasn't me
saying that was Jackson and as much as I
loved it
I I think I'll just stick to my side of
the road
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh